hello everybody i hope you are doing
well wherever you are listening to this
and i appreciate your time so i will be
talking today about some recent updates
to ncbi virus including a tool called
the sars cove 2 variants overview i'm
going to spend a few minutes on why it's
worthwhile to spend our efforts on
specialized resources for viruses then
i'll present some of the improvements
we've made to facilitate access to sars
cove2 sequence data
so after over two years of living in an
international pandemic you can't have
escaped hearing about viruses
but what exactly are they
they are extremely small for one you
cannot see most of them unless you have
a specialized microscope and they
require machinery inside of a host cell
in order to replicate themselves
viruses have a core of nucleic acids
which is their genome and that's
surrounded by a protective capsid so
they kind of look like a popular candy
that doesn't melt in your hand
the genome can take many different forms
which is why
it can complicate how we store and
analyze the genomic sequence data
understanding viruses is crucial to
human health it's estimated that three
out of four emerging human diseases are
from animals
called zoonoses and most of these are
viruses
this is not a problem that is going away
anytime soon in fact scientists predict
an increasing risk of zoonoses through
and through increasing contact between
wild animals and humans or their
livestock which creates opportunities
for spillover of pathogens so spillover
from a natural host into a human host
humans travel and that can lead to
faster spread of new pathogens to wider
geographic areas
also climate change can expand the range
of insects that carry diseases
several coronaviruses have historically
been zoonoses and coronaviruses have a
wide variety of animals as their natural
reservoirs so this is a phylogenetic
tree showing the relationships between
various groups of coronaviruses some are
responsible for mild but common diseases
like a cold that you might get in the
winter and others cause much more severe
infections like middle east respiratory
syndrome or mers and of course severe
acute respiratory syndrome sars and sars
coronavirus ii importantly it seems that
several of these viruses including those
related to fars exist in the wild as a
group of closely related but diverse
viruses
meaning that there may be more viruses
that are not recognized but have the
potential to cause severe human disease
there are many ways to try to understand
viruses how they spread and predict
which ones may cause disease or why some
of them cause more severe disease
studying their genomic sequence data is
one of those ways
genetic data carries the instructions
for building the tools that give viruses
and other organisms their abilities and
their characteristics
ncbi virus is a suite of value-added
resources that provide sequence data and
they currently feature stars chronovirus
ii but all viruses are available through
ncbi virus
most people don't necessarily want every
single publicly available sequence
record so we have a variety of filters
that narrow down your data set based on
normalized metadata
we also are big fans of using
visualizations to explore data and
downloaded data can be in a in the form
of genomic sequence or individual open
reading frames and we have flexible
download menus to minimize the amount of
extra work that you have to do to clean
up the data before you continue working
it
so what kind of data can you get from
ncbi virus resources where we pull in
the sequence data and the metadata that
describes it from genbank
that includes data from infdc partners
based in europe and japan
we also pull in some data from
bioproject and biosample which are
descriptive records
for sequences
and then we're starting to pull in data
from fra which holds raw data or
sequence reads that are usually
assembled into the genomes that you
might find through genbank and we're
also doing
taxonomy for viruses and we create
refseqs that are reference sequences for
a particular species the sequences that
you can go to to see what the genome
tends to look like or find important
proteins that might be on that genome
we worked with eric milwaukee who's a
researcher he's in the research branch
of ncbi and also the genbank submissions
team to develop a tool to annotate
annotate and validate sequences as part
of the submission process
the viral annotation diviner or vader
can be used to annotate the positions of
genes and the proteins on a variety of
sequence types this makes data more
useful because you can identify the
tools that a virus codes for it helps to
ensure data quality and it significantly
reduces the processing time for
submission of a virus and released to
the public
by submission of virus sequence and
released to the public
all of these proteins are also
they're stored in ncbi virus so you can
either access information for the entire
genome or for the individual proteins
and for various reasons data descriptors
in ncbi databases can be quite variable
so as a data consumer normalized
metadata makes it possible to build data
sets that are relevant to you so we have
a semi-automated curation process
once the sequence record is publicly
available we pick it up usually within
an hour or two and we normalize various
fields so for example the isolate source
field describes the part of a host where
a sample was pulled from and it can
contain terms like serum pbmcs plasma
samples and so on that we match up to
one single term which is blood
we also create and maintain uh the viral
respects so as i mentioned there's
usually one refseq per species so
they're useful as examples of high level
of viral diversity but when there is a
an important virus that is in the human
population
we also tend to make a restrict for that
too so we have a refseq for the original
sars virus from i think it was around
2003 and we also have a refseq for the
sars coronavirus 2
virus that emerged recently
one of the benefits to having a
specialized resource for viral data is
that we can respond quickly when there's
an epidemic or pandemic so this is a
screenshot of our ncbi virus search
interface it incorporates a variety of
filters that can be applied to the
sequence data and a table showing your
results and the normalized metadata
we developed several new features to
support accessing sars cove 2 data so
every day we check for updates to the
pangolin tools which is a
common tool for classifying the lineages
of stars coronavirus ii
and we run that pangolin classification
on all stars code 2 sequences
every night
the classifications are available
through the ncbi virus results table and
if you download the fasta or the
metadata table including the pango field
it will automatically include the
versions of the pangolin tool so you
know which version of the tool was used
to get those results
you can search for viruses from a
country or from a u.s state newly
released sequences or randomly sampled
sequences which should be more
representative of lineage frequencies
out in the wild
you can work with either genomic
sequences
proteins or cvs or amino acid sequences
and while the main ncbi virus results
table only provides genbank data
data so only the assembled
sequences you can still search using sra
accessions bio project or biosample
accessions which are from the same
sample as the genbank record so it helps
to work across the different ncbi
databases
once you've narrowed down your data set
you can explore the results through a
multiple sequence alignment which
highlights the mutations and displays
some of the metadata you can also
quickly generate a phylogenetic tree
from your sequence data however both of
these tools can only be run with a
limited data set of about 500 sequences
but it's a nice way to be able to verify
that the data set that you're working
with is what you think it is
we also provide flexible download
formats
sequence data can be downloaded as fasta
files either the nucleotide sequence
just a coding region or a protein
sequence
and the metadata included in the fasta
deaf line is customizable
you can also get a list of accessions or
you can download a table of the
normalized metadata describing your data
set
okay i'm going to switch topics here
just a little bit
over the course of the pandemic you've
probably heard a lot about vaccines
antibodies and spike proteins but here's
a short overview
spike proteins decorate the outside of a
virus when they come into contact with
receptor on a host cell or on a human
cell they act like a key opening a door
and allowing the virus inside the cell
and then it can replicate and lead to
disease in that host
so through natural infection or through
a vaccine your body can develop
antibodies that stick to the spike kind
of like putting tape over a key so it
can't fit in the door lock anymore
but the antibodies only stick if they
can recognize the spike protein the
spike has to look like the same protein
that the antibody was created for
so if the virus develops mutations that
change the way that the spike looks to
the antibody then the antibody may not
work as well or at all
so in response to the sars cove 2
pandemic the national institutes of
health initiated a collaboration called
active trace which stands for the
accelerating covid19 therapeutic
interventions of vaccines that's active
tracking resistance and coronavirus
evolution trace initiative
our primary goal as part of this
collaboration was to support accurate
sequence analyses
needed to track the mutations and
prioritize emerging variants
that may not bind well to antibodies or
which may not be as treatable through
the therapeutics that we have available
so once identified computationally those
variants can be studied in wet bench
experiments and we can promote sharing
of the genome sequences with researchers
and with public health groups
and because we were prepared for
large-scale analyses
the team decided to go with a
cloud-hosted pipeline then delivered the
results of that pipeline to a web page
hosted on premises
we also decided to use raw read data in
addition to the assembled sequence data
that's in genbank the raw sequence data
is held in the sequence we read archive
you may have heard that called sra
because it's not averaged to generate a
genome sequence the data allows
identification of major and minor
variants
these records are also extremely large
so it's convenient to take advantage of
technical tools like cloud storage or
machine learning to do analyses and then
we can share the results with a wide
variety of people who may not have
access to those technical tools
besides the amount of data another
challenge that we had was how to
identify the groups of viruses that may
warrant further investigation so people
refer to stars cove two lineages like
pango that you're probably familiar with
those are names like
b.1.617 and they're grouped at fairly
high resolution so sequences within a
pango lineage are pretty similar to each
other
this is also the lineage the
classification scheme that's most used
in research and epidemiological studies
for our purposes though it had a huge
detriment which is that the pangolin
classification tools
can't process unassembled sequences so
we would lose all of that unique data
sets that are in sra so a team at ncbi
developed a method for assigning pango
equivalent lineages
through sets of defining mutations so we
have curators who identify the mutations
that are required for each lineage and
then each mutation must be present in a
particular sequence in order for it to
get classified as that lineage
we've also done some studies so we
verified that the way that we are
assigning the pango classification
has very very high correlation with the
way that sequences like whole genome
sequences are assigned using the um the
classic pangolin tools
the pipeline we ended up with was pretty
complicated it involves many people in
several different teams at ncbi as well
as outside collaborators so in one step
of the pipeline sequence data from
genbank and sra go through a validation
step
contigs are built for unassembled data
and then mutations are identified by
comparing to the refseq in a separate
second step the mutations identified in
sequences are compared to the lineage
defining mutation sets and then sequence
records get classified as tango lineages
finally the data is aggregated with
sample metadata such as the collection
date or location so it can be served up
to accessible cloud directories or our
variants overview website that i'll be
talking about more in a minute
so we have all this data that's coming
out of the pipeline literally millions
of data points a researcher interested
in the data could get lost among the
many files of output and like the saying
goes they might get lost in the trees
and not be able to see the shape of the
forest
so if you've been to the nih campus or
perhaps you've seen a map like
with the the trees and not the roads and
everything highlighted you might
recognize this area though but most
people even if they're familiar with an
area probably won't recognize that top
box just because it's overwhelming even
though it's still accurate
if you label the items that are here you
start to become more familiar with what
you're actually seeing so it becomes
more understandable but you still
maintain accuracy
but if you're only looking for one
particular place it's still too much
information to be useful so you might
want some kind of highlight on only what
you are interested in our goal with the
sars cove two variants overview was like
that we wanted to summarize the
potentially overwhelming sequence data
and help customers find the data that
they're most interested in all without
losing any accuracy
the sars coke 2 overview
sorry the scope 2 variants overview is
an example of how visualizations help
convey the stories in the data
over the past couple of years it's
emphasized that people involved in
pandemic response are often severely
short on time groups may not have access
to a biofermentation
so we could help to support public
health efforts by providing information
on mutation-based lineages and their
spread so this helps to support pandemic
response
public health needs getting information
out to people as quickly as possible and
the information that we're using for
this is really developed through global
efforts to sample and sequence fires
coronavirus ii
so people who are going out there and
doing the swabs and collecting the
samples and really have put tremendous
effort into
making this data publicly available
we identified common questions that a
researcher or someone in public health
might have
we address these questions through our
sars co2 variants overview webpage
this is an interactive dashboard that
summarizes the where when and who
of pango lineage selected by the united
states cdc so this page only includes
variants of interest variants being
monitored variants of concern and
variance of high consequence if we're
ever unfortunate enough to identify one
as mentioned previously this resource is
unique in that it seamlessly combines
unassembled and assembled sequence data
from sra and genbank
as well as the sample descriptors from
biosample and bio project
we also use the biosample data to
identify when a single sample is
represented by data in genbank and sra
so that sample isn't counted twice in
the data that we're showing to customers
and if you're interested in trying this
out you can go to the url that's shown
there or you can search ncbi virus in
most web browsers when that page comes
up you can click that button yellow the
button highlighted by yellow the
variance overview button
okay
so our first user story that we
identified was what mutations are
associated with the lineage and what
risk factors might be associated with
that lineage so all of these lineages
with a cdc status are listed on the left
of the webpage highlighted there in
yellow
customers can search by pango lineage
who greek letter or by cdc status
and each lineage has its own little info
panel showing the lineage-defining
mutation set that was developed by the
curators here at ncbi
the info panels can also be expanded to
show key mutations or in this case
variations because we use the amino acid
positions for the mutations
these are in epitopes or binding sites
identified by our protein domains team
we also link to web pages developed by
another active trace participant called
ncats and they've gathered data on the
effectiveness of therapeutics against
various fires cove 2 lineages
an info panel can be clicked to select a
lineage and then the other displays on
the page will highlight how often the
lineage is sampled and in what locations
several members of active trace are from
pharmaceutical companies and it's
important for them to know which
lineages are growing in the countries
which use their therapeutics so that
they can be sure that their therapeutic
will still continue to work against the
lineage
so we show the frequency of the cdc
status lineages over the past several
months and use a metric called doubling
time or how quickly we expect to have
twice the current number of records to
highlight quickly growing lineages
pop-ups allow customers to dig into the
data and see actual counts as well as
frequency of records which helps with
interpretation
another question many people are
interested in is which lineages have
been detected in my state or my country
when no lineages are selected the u.s
states and countries are colored to show
the number of samples classified as a
lineage with cdc status and if a lineage
is selected then the maps only show the
counts for that lineage
clicking on a location also generates a
popup with lineage counts
the total number of samples and the
number of lineage records collected over
all time
and although the current version of the
stars cove two variants overview
addresses several customer needs we do
have plans for for many different
improvements that we'd like to make in
the future
so the teams begin collecting and
reviewing usage data from logging on the
page
presentations to audiences and user
interviews we also would love to get
your feedback so there's a yellow
feedback button that stays in the bottom
right of the webpage when you access it
you can just type in your comments there
so we're making data driven improvements
to the resource and we know that
customers are interested in being able
to see all the mutations associated with
the lineage and mutation on individual
mutations in general so we'll be adding
that in the future we also hope to
enhance the options for downloading the
data since many people would like to be
able to perform their own analyses on
this valuable and unique data set
and to finish off i just wanted to say i
am sincerely grateful to the many people
who have contributed to the work that i
presented today um there's several teams
at ncbi highlighted on the slide
and i'm personally privileged to work
with all these talented and hardworking
people
we also appreciate the work of our
external collaborators the people
collecting samples and submitters
because none of this would be possible
without their efforts and finally thank
you for your time and attention and i am
very happy to take some questions if
there are any
examiner um i'll give people a chance
here to put some questions in the pot i
don't have any open ones right now but i
have a couple of questions so in terms
of the sampling of the and
what we're getting into the database
how has that changed over time and are
we still getting you know
adequate surveillance of what's out
there in the wild right now because it
seems like
with the current if you're thinking
about the united states with the current
resurgence
you know it seems to me that everybody
that i know is getting covered but those
people are not
getting their you know dna check they're
just basically doing an at-home cove
test positive they isolate for a few
days
and mostly they're okay
but you know it seems to me like we're
not getting as much
of that data in as we once before is
that the case
or how does that work yeah the amount of
the sequencing rate sorry the like the
submission rate
has dropped so we are receiving fewer
sars cove two sequences however there
are some um like
federally funded national efforts
to kind of randomly sample from the
population so
the number the amount of sampling that
happens
really depends on what kind of questions
need to be answered at that particular
time so early on we just needed to see
where is the virus at this point right
remember when it was
is it in washington state or is it in
north carolina
and then it kind of changed to
how is the virus evolving what kind of
mutations is it picking up what does it
look like compared to the antibodies
developed against the vaccine and so
that's a lot of the sequencing that
we've been seeing over the past several
months
recently though sequencing efforts have
kind of tamped down
because being able to do this
general
lower level but
across the population sequencing lets us
identify any potential viruses that have
mutations that could be more risky that
might allow for escape from antibodies
or from therapeutics i'm always a big
fan like i think the more data that we
have it's always better but obviously
there's there's funding that goes into
it like it has to be justified to answer
the questions that people are asking now
thanks thanks and i have i have a sort
of a random question that has always
bothered me and that's this
this pangolin name
[Music]
what
what is the origin of that because it
remember early on
there were penguins were considered to
be a possible
source
for stars
just the coincidence that it's called
pangolin
no it's you know scientists are funny
sometimes
we try to make jokes
um so early on um because it was one of
the things that like we thought that it
may have originated in pangolins and i'm
not sure that that's been completely
excluded or not
but it's it's an acronym
that could be used for the
classification system so i can't
remember what it stands for but it is an
acronym for a longer
classification name
um
but it but it's more than a question
there's something it's more than a
coincidence yeah it's more than a
coincidence yeah because they called it
pangolin okay maybe
right i understand but so they sort of
came up with an acronym that fit that
animal's name yeah that's the initial um
interest in that okay um oh and so uh
rana has put in the uh
chat
the actually what that acronym is it's
phylogenetic assignment of named global
outbreak lineages
and so you can make that into pangolin
if you leave that yeah i do have to say
like most of the classification systems
that we have for other viruses
uh it works a little bit different
because
we have sparse collection right so if
there's an outbreak you might only get a
handful of sequences but with this
outbreak we have a really dense set so
you have very very few mutations when
comparing from one sequence to another
one so it really was important to have
a classification system that could
handle
the density of sequences that we were
getting
yeah and i mean in some ways this is an
unprecedented natural experiment where
we have
so many
copies of this virus out in the world
yes absolutely this opportunity for
evolution so we do have another question
an actual question from a participant
this person asks are there any plans for
an api or
other programmatic access to ncbi virus
or maybe does that already exist yes
okay so there's a tool that currently
exists called data sets so you can just
search for ncbi data sets that's only
for stars coronavirus 2
data or coronavirus genomes but they
have very good explanations of how to
use the data sets tool either through
command line or through api to access
the data
if you have any trouble with it or for
some reason it doesn't satisfy your
needs please reach out to
ncbi because we would love to hear like
how we can make improvements to our
tools
and i've put that um the url direct url
to data sets in the chat but that's
a good point and that's a way to delve
to get access to lots of different kinds
of genome-related data and there's a
special there's a special package for
source kobe 2 that you can get from that
right
that's right yeah i know in the future
they have plans for adding
access to to all the virus data that we
have in ncbi virus so they are using
like the normalized metadata that we are
showing on our resource too
that's that's in the future though for
now i think it's limited to mostly stars
cove two and there are some things that
you can pull for coronaviruses in
general
yes and if you go to the
if you go to the data sets homepage and
you just scroll down there's a whole
section
on sars kobe 2 genomes as far as kobe 2
proteins and there's some explanations
of how to do things with those resources
right there on the page
okay so uh thanks everybody for coming
and thank you very much united and one
thing that came up a couple times in the
chat is
everyone would like to have your slides
so if it's okay with you i'll go ahead
and just send those to me i'll put them
up on that ftp site for people to get
access to
okay yeah perfect and thanks for the
opportunity sure great to have you bye
bye thanks
you